[Music]
feeling like a failure or what passed
you by
I can't take any more rejection honey
you remember Kevin Wow so what's your
plan now that you've been kicked out of
school
I've taken a temporary position and a
public relations firm did you always
know this is what you wanted to do or
did you want to do another thing first
like did I dream of figure skating but
my parents wouldn't pay for the lessons
you don't want to be a temp forever do
you get got a letter for you get ready
get ready for what
[Music]
you have come to the store kitchen and I
am the salesman behold we sell what you
need unicorns
always the only thing I ever wanted if I
have one brought here I have to know
that you're for real I've made a
decision
I'm building a home worthy of you
unicorn was thinking something like a
stable I don't think a pony wants to
live in your basement it's a good point
do you think this is some kind of joke
should we just get you a puppy I know
that I'm just a disappointment or always
like why don't you have a boyfriend or
why are you just more like Kevin Oh
someone call me no don't know how to be
a grown up my parents think that I'm
insane honey what is really going on
this is crazy
the most grown-up thing you can do is
fail at things you really care about you
need to learn to love you silly get out
there show us what you can do
you got that
everybody needs some magic in their
lives
even if they're all grown up
tell me where does this unicorn come
from the unicorn star oh of course
[Music]
you